um since none of you know where that is
this is a small R&D company located in
the DC area at National Harbor we have a
ferris wheel and we're located in a
little office in the back there what we
do so we have over 13 years of
experience moving research and AI and
data science through the math science
and engineering steps necessary to make
the jump from theory to practice
currently have three projects and data
privacy we're working with DARPA
Brandeis we're working with the US
Census Bureau and we're providing
technical leadership for the NIST
differentially privacy differential
privacy synthetic data challenge so this
is probably the only talk this workshop
it has audience participation and worth
$80,000 oh yeah feel free to tune out
for the first two parts if you want to
but you should pay attention for the
third all right so at Nexus our priority
is to develop the tools and technologies
necessary to facilitate safe successful
public adoption of new research concepts
and we're gonna be talking about our
work with that on the DARPA brandeis
project we are working on noise
resistant decision metrics and the
application here is privatized analysis
of the call text graph to alert
emergency responders at crisis onset
this was a set of slides that had to go
through three agencies I'm not speaking
for anyone so uh hmm so this is what the
system looks like here a high-level what
we're talking about we have a crisis in
a city it originates at a city block
people call each other this is going to
show up and the see the our data and
this is plenty of social science
research documenting this what we have
here is just plain old simple laplacian
noise call volume counts in the city
blocks and the question is can we from
this determine which block the crisis
originated in maybe information about
the severity of the crisis we started
out our work building the social network
generator because what we wanted to do
was build crisis detection that works
you can be 80% off sorry it can be 80%
correct if what you are trying to do is
release a number but if what you're
trying to do is release a decision
you're either 100% correct or you're
100% wrong and if you're only right 80
percent of the time that means out of
one of one out of five times you're
calling wolf so it's not really
something that you can afford to do so
we started out by building a data
synthesizer that would let us test how
well our metrics worked over lots of
different data situations we built the
system that you just saw web application
and then we started in on our crisis
detection metrics and evaluating how
well they did a little bit of theory
here so if i'm looking at communications
data i'm looking at social network data
whether i have the social network or not
that's what's going on obviously
differential privacy over social
networks is an interesting game we're
not doing node privacy or edge privacy
we're doing contributor privacy which
offers privacy at the level of one row
of the adjacency matrix all right so
let's try this I wanted to attack a
crisis what should I do
something bad happens there's a shooting
attack people freak out they start
calling I'm going to see a spike in call
volume
nice a simple analysis sensitivity of
one what is the spike due to the crisis
or the noise so here is how we are
computing error everybody likes the same
mean squared error this is what we mean
for us here's the ground truth the
crisis is actually here here's an
example of a series of things we could
get wrong we could think that there was
another crisis over there a false alarm
we could put a warning in a place where
there's not a crisis we could also fail
to check the actual crisis and so for
our mean squared error here we're
counting up all the mistakes we made in
each iteration and you think ok maybe
this is sort of ok if I look at this
from Epsilon
you know point wide it's kind of got
that nice flat curve but again we really
can't afford mistakes and if I make this
if I tell you how many mistakes we're
making here it's a fair amount we need
to do better so we'll try and do better
and this is where in order to do better
we actually have to understand the
behavior the social science of what's
going on in our data so it turns out an
actual crisis people call out and then
their friends call back in to check on
them there's a second spike and that's
showing up in all the literature on this
it's very well understood um so we're
like ok let's try detecting the second
spike well so first we're going to look
for the first spike and then the second
spike and that gets us a little bit more
accuracy if we insist on seeing two
spikes we do a little bit better but
honestly not that much better so we need
to understand even more what's going on
with the people and what's going on with
the data
this one also doesn't work and I have a
lot to get through so no there we go but
now we start to get to one that does so
how do I know that you are the people
are calling out because of a crisis
versus they're calling out because of a
football game or something other random
well it turns out the weight of the
information I'm communicating changes
the impact it has if I'm calling out due
to a crisis you receive that call then
you start calling people that you know
spread the information further and so
the
initial social science analysis to
determine the spread of this further
information are not things we can easily
privatize they involve you know tracking
down things to specific individuals but
we can on aggregate
again sensitivity want all we're doing
is partitions of call volumes here but
we can in aggregate look at how the call
volume from the crisis block changes the
outgoing call volume of the blocks that
are receiving most of the calls from the
crisis block
and that works quite well
so there we go now we're starting to get
into something useful and they were
interesting social science math and
engineering problems and needed to be
solved understanding people's behavior
in order to get us down to a point where
we had a nice epsilon 0.5 no false
detection and that's starting to get
down to practicality so that's my
takeaway there for this third which is
that it pays to understand the data and
especially it pays to understand social
behavior and to try and capture those
patterns sort of as closely as
efficiently as we can with privatised
metrics wait okay since then for
something entirely different
okay so myself Mike hi Nick
Jason swagga Christine hi scrum begat Jo
grouse Konrad rauscher Jeffrey Hodges
and Jonathan would L at Nexus are
working on the Simpson project where
we're providing research engineering
software development effort for ongoing
census privacy efforts we're developing
effective usable software systems that
address the problem of data privacy so
there's a few people from the Census
here and I did not know what all they'd
be talking about so I picked something
that they probably wouldn't be talking
about we're going to look at our
evaluation suite I think this was
mentioned yesterday in the panel the
question of how do we tell if we have
good data and that is an open and
fascinating problem and so our
evaluation suites is designed to address
it and it's applicable to synthetic data
and research synthetic data research in
general even though it was developed for
the non synthetic or sorry the non
differentially private synthetic data
for the 2019 ICS okay so I'm gonna take
a moment and do something boring but you
should all pay attention anyways and I'm
gonna go through the definition of
synthetic data and that's partly because
this video is going to be archived and I
want this to be available for other
people but it's partly because maybe we
shouldn't pay attention to it
so given a data set d if any of the
schema s a synthetic replacement for D
refers to an artificially generated data
set if it's the same schema and is
distributionally similar you want
overlap on individual rows between the
two data sets should be quite a purely
coincidental and it should happen sort
of reasonably low probability there's a
lot of different ways for producing it
in general it's usually produced by
capturing the distribution of the data
in some fashion and then sampling
another data set from that same
distribution high quality synthetic
Survey data should ideally be as similar
to the original data as to uniform
random partitions of the original data
are to each other if I'm producing a
synthetic data set and I can tell the
data users that it's no further off from
real data than sampling error then
essentially if I had you know reached my
hand into another universe full of
completely different paper people but
living in more or less exactly the same
circumstances that's when it becomes
something that's comfortable to use
privacy preserving data generators can
be iteratively tested and improved
safely using previously repeat released
public data sets of the target schema
where available so helpful for ACS to
see looking at the 1940 census data okay
so the obvious question
how closely we go pay attention don't
really argue if you like but this is how
I understand synthetic data so so the
obvious question is similar how
synthetic data should be similar but
what do we mean so that's what we're
looking at always good to have a first
check right first take it the problem
makes sense to look at individual
variables of interest to verify that
their values are distributed similarly
between the two data sets so basically
histograms basically tables so the
census has a wide variety of tables and
our table based evaluator and I should
say evaluator suite I'm going to show a
variety of ways that you could evaluate
synthetic data evaluator suite here we
have a synthesizer with the this is a
multiple imputation based synthesizer
and this is with one variable ordering
this is with a different one this
variable ordering is better and here we
have the cells where there is
significant variance between the real
data and the synthetic data are
highlighted and is because of
evaluations like this that we know the
variable ordering can have an impact and
that is one of the math and engineering
problems that we're investigating
okay multiple imputation based synthesis
so the idea is given a data set with a
series of features you are essentially
modeling the data set with those
features in order so you model the third
feature based on the values for the
first two you modeled the fourth feature
based on the values for the first three
and so on and the better potentially you
might assume that the the better the
early availables predict the later ones
so the the more the independent
variables are earlier in the ordering
you do better but maybe not we're not
sure what we know is the variable
ordering has an impact Thanks so we're
looking enjoy
okay so there's just tables though
that's maybe two or three correlations
but let's look at correlations more
deeply so as part of the NIST
differential privacy synthetic data
challenge which we will be getting to
later there we had a problem where we
need to efficiently snapshot how good
the synthetic data we were getting was
one of the first methods we came up with
that that we used in match one was a
three marginal based metric so using
different we here that was actually
created by dr. Sergey Pokagon who is a
basically a tech leads for top coder
what they call copilot I so three
marginals turn out to be very flexible
and this was a randomized sample of
three marginals computed very nicely
caught some good patterns samplings over
the variables yes yeah we did not do all
K choose three possible three marginals
it's a random sampling such that every
variable ends up in at least one three
marginal okay so this was published on
the news sites you can all go to the
challenge site and read the details of
how this metric is computed it gives a
nice number between zero and two after
it was published we saw the use of that
over on the Simpson project and added
this to our evaluation suite as a ke
marginal we will compute all in choose K
possible marginals for you there it may
take a while we allow you know
customized pocketing we do data
subselection filtering we give more
detailed reports on where variations
occur if they are there and we basically
let you use that to inspect where your
synthetic data is starting to deviate
from your real data threw it up though
it's still in some sense sort of
randomized heuristic so something more
holistic doctor Clare Bowen so she was
I did her dissertation on differentially
private synthetic data at the University
of Notre Dame possibly dumb developed a
technique called the spec's method and
so this is synthetic data generation
propensity score matching empirical CDF
comparison based on call magrav Smirnoff
hmm and basically what that gets us is a
graph like this so this is using her
suggested approach with the logistic
logistic regression and this is a tune
synthesizer where you only see one line
that's because they're actually
performing so well the logistic
regression can't distinguish the two
data sets so basically your approach
here is you're training a classifier to
distinguish between the real in the
synthetic data and then that gets
computed down into one nice single
number that you can use this is a
built-in synthesizer this is a very
poorly to sentient synthesizer see the
difference okay so at Nexus we have our
own not quite in the evaluation suite
yet it's a prototype but it works pretty
well one thing it lets us do is it lets
us substitute other classifiers in and
so here we can see that using
multi-layer perceptron Network actually
gets us more more distinguishing power
more just coming into power then we did
open the logistic regression so now we
can see we haven't done a perfect job
are those differences problematic it's a
good question right we know they exist
maybe they're fine
that is Oh the plots on the right sorry
so well tuned synthesizer poorly tuned
synthesizer good performance bad
performance yes yeah so this is just the
it's the CDF of the propensity score of
the classifier this is a fascinating
conversation I would love to take
offline but part of this is this is this
is what she's with done in her work and
I won't speak for her either but but I'd
be happy to talk to you about it and her
dissertations fascinating yeah
absolutely
and yeah we don't have a baseline here
in in this particular two diagrams I've
given you that does not have so sorry
yes we do expect there to be some
deviation there is a question of whether
the deviation that we're seeing here is
a significant or problematic desired
deviation and that was me leading up to
my next slide so okay so in general
though right it's easy for us to just
immediately talk about sort of open
problems things to think about here
right evaluation for synthetic data is
the topic of challenging active and
vitally important research and we are
not providing any canonical answers
today but the evaluation suite is
designed to support that research and
things that we will be adding to it
include the analytics package so the
idea here is a set of analytics that
look at things from the social science
data users perspective and this
is again to determine if we're starting
to see two data sets the diverge are
they diverging in a way that's
problematic we have some PCA techniques
we have looked at which gives us a nice
visual representation and then there are
other NIST challenge heuristics that we
intend to add to the suite as they come
available okay any questions before
[Music]
category I mean what considered by cool
the flag nerd you know other distance
metrics between distributions so the KS
is getting applied literally just to
look at the distance between these two
lines here but but again let me make
this bit clearer
there are certainly more things we can
do and anybody who wants to talk to me
about things that we can do I will be
happy I will take notes I will exchange
emails absolutely
we are we good to get onto the the
$80,000 part of the talk then this
differential privacy synthetic data
challenge okay so this is a this is
initiative by the NIST's public safety
communications research division and the
the two leads on the project
Mary Thea fanos is the P I and Theresa
Manley is the prize manager with PSCR
I'm providing differential privacy
expertise and technical leadership
topcoder is the challenge platform
they're doing implementation and also
project management hero X was the
challenge platform for phase 1 and Kyla
still very much helpful for project
management this is the first national
challenge in differential privacy and we
expect developments coming out of this
competition to drive major advances in
practical applications especially for
contacts such as Public Safety
why don't you match to will be announced
tomorrow actually do I have any
competitors in this room who feel
comfortable raising their hands thank
you awesome all right so very soon guys
match three begins next week on Sunday
and registration is open now and we'll
tell you more about how that works as we
go so let me tell you just a little bit
about the public safety communications
research division PSC are so they are
their purpose is to drive research they
can possibly help Americans first
responders this is actually very
important data analysis and privacy
concerns because most fire departments
don't employ data analysts but obviously
being able to understand if your fire
department is providing adequate service
to your city is a data analysis problem
but it's a data analysis problem with
significant privacy implications
and so they are hoping that by funding
this challenge they're going to drive
research that will allow safety
departments to leverage the power of
crowd-sourced analysis to understand and
improve their systems challenge also has
advantages for us so challenges provide
researchers with a visible open and
accessible shared the pathway from
theory to practice they grab attention
they educate the public and potential
investors about new technological
possibilities inviting the audience to
follow along and the excitement as those
possibilities are fulfilled and this is
already happening
people with TopCoder have been going too
and people with PS area been going to
the the big data conferences and there
was a lot of excitement and this is why
challenges often precede significant
acceleration the development of
commercial products for new tech as we
have all seen happen with the with Cagle
obviously with the DARPA urban challenge
and so on so what is the challenge in
case anybody doesn't know so I begin in
the summer of 2018 with a concept
building phase we had white papers and
those were evaluated and put up for
public judging and we got sole on the
hero X platform we got prizes out of
that and then we moved on to the second
phase which started this fall and this
is a sequence of empirical matches where
participants implemented their systems
and competed to produce high quality
synthetic data from real data sets it
was the first national challenge in
differential privacy I like saying that
I've said that like three times but it's
already not the last so top coder has
already launched a second one I'm not
involved with that and I'm not sure who
is actually someone is but this is why
we think that as the data challenge
format is a well-established archetype
and people in data science are
interested in this and we may see more
data science based differentially
privacy challenges those requires some
non-trivial adaptations to actually work
we think those are questions that are
important for the community to address
so what you're going to see here is a
series of questions and complications
that we ran into and how we resolve them
and our reasoning but we don't think
these are the only possible solutions
this was our first shot in it so we're
very much interested in what you guys
think and so on all right so let's talk
about the challenge things that we had
to figure out in order to do the
challenge we had to we wanted to write
for the contest procedure we needed to
create a shared competitive benchmarking
process for differentially private
synthetic data generators I know it was
a constraint which is we haven't really
had one of those before if we did this
is a one and done we would have problems
because the contestants are learning
about the behavior of their solutions on
our scoring metrics and in this context
at the same time we are so what we
needed was for the contest to support
teams iteratively evaluating exploring
and then refining and resubmitting their
solutions so we wanted to support not
just a chance to have a great contest
look nice and hand out prizes but
actually support the evaluation and
refinement process the development
process so the way we're doing this and
this is actually sort of a common
problem in data science contests in
general is with the TopCoder marathon
match which is a great forum so we're
doing three marathon matches of
increasing difficulty each match has
five weeks a provisional leaderboard
scoring and the way that works is you
just submit us the synthetic data set
you get a score on the leaderboard you
next day you want to try again maybe you
submit an get a better score
this is followed by three weeks of
rigorous sequestered evaluations so at
the end of the at the end of the
provisional leaderboard phase we have
everybody submit there everybody above a
certain point level we'll get into this
we invite them to submit their source
code and their executable systems and we
do a very robust evaluation and it's
that robust evaluation that determines
the prizes a question that came up
to support iterative refinement without
violating differential privacy we assume
that the data set that we give you
during the provisional phase is public
so this is again sort of the the ACS or
there's many other sorts of datasets out
there that have been releasing
anonymized public datasets for years so
you already have information about the
data and basically our imaginary use
case here is that a group like that
wants to switch to using differentially
private synthetic data and and so you
have all of that all of those years of
public data available to you so refine
your algorithm and your understanding
and then you just have to get the
differential privacy right on that last
private data set and so the deal here
for anybody who might be interested in
competing is that the provisional data
is public you can use it however you
want to you can hard code things from
the provisional data into your interior
system the sequestered data is different
years or areas different individuals and
different distributions and possibly a
different schema and so please don't
hard-code too much okay yeah maybe
you're gonna get to this what are you
what is the sequestered evaluation
evaluating right so we we will get it
there's a slide titled scoring it is the
same scoring that's used on the
leaderboard what we do is area under the
curve as many epsilon as necessary to be
able to confidently rank the solutions I
have a came up recently all right we're
gonna move quickly
so differential privacy validation so
obviously the thing everybody's worried
about easiest way to get a high score
for synthetic data it's just give us
back the data set we gave you violate
differential privacy and it's also very
easy to do accidentally and it's very
easy to do subtly and accidentally it
would be great to have automated DP
verification but we did not have at
least we have not had so
are the time and manpower to do an
implementation of one of those systems
came out more or less in the midst of
our setting up the whole contest so what
we use instead is a SME review panel I
have every confidence in them they have
found a number of very subtle of
mistakes mistakes that took me quite a
while to figure out how to explain to
the person who made them subtle mistakes
but we have to be conscientious of their
time and so what we actually have is a
two step process during the provisional
phase every Monday we have a telecon we
do a quick skim on all of the clear
complete privacy proofs that have been
submitted you submit your privacy proof
you submit your algorithm right up and
you get a thousand times point boost on
the leaderboard you fly to the top of
the leaderboard on the sequestered phase
invited contestants submit code code
guide and documentation and an updated
privacy algorithm specification and
privacy proof and this is when we pick
through everything through a fine-tooth
comb it is very common for us to find
things that are problems in the
sequestered phase that we missed when we
first gave you the pre-screening and the
the provisional phase
okay so data and scoring data should be
relevant to PS CRS applications we had
to go looking for a good data set the
the got it their needs what we used for
match one was the San Francisco fire
event data so here's this thing topcoder
has a policy and it's very fair that I
can't tell any of you anything directly
that we don't post online for all the
possible contestants to see at the same
time so so you can't have a special
advantage so there's a black box and
match three at the moment but we'll see
about that all right so on scoring we
talked a little bit about this before so
the provisional scoring is done on the
synthetic data sets you just submit us
three data sets at three values of
epsilon we score them the score goes up
on the leaderboard
so question final scoring is area under
the curve and repeated trials yeah it is
yes so it is very similar it is given
columns may switch order so there's a
single table yes so so the schema
between the provisional and sequestered
is maintained
except for columns may switch order
their values
please don't hard-code to the values
that actually exist in the data set that
we give you but rather to the set of
possible they are values in the schema
no it is always real data sets it is
real data sorry it is real data we are
not messing with it how similar is it I
can't tell that no it is true the 2018
is true similar to 2017 and what I
highly recommend doing is looking at the
winners announcement when we post that
tomorrow on match two and it gives
analysis of the sequestered evaluation
from match two and that'll tell you a
little bit more about things
oh the data is all of the data is
already publicly available
you just don't know which one it's
actually already publicly available you
just didn't know which year we were
using all right so I don't how am i
doing on time okay well we're gonna
maybe going into questions a little bit
okay so in match one we used a
randomized normalized three merge that
rhymes three marginal based distance
metric in match two we used a row
similarity metric so the idea was pick a
random row from the the real data and
look at this pool of rows that are
similar to that row in the real data see
if that same pool is of a similar size
and the synthetic data so essentially
looking at full row based distributional
similarity and I would
happy to explain that in more detail at
any points and we have another black box
okay this is an important one
so NIST is part of the US Department of
Commerce and they provide guidance that
helps US corporations address technical
needs as a vital outcome of this contest
we would like to have stable usable
well-engineered and ideally open-source
software solutions they can be further
evaluated by NIST experts contributing
toward NIST's efforts to offer official
guidance on DP synthetic data so we were
hoping to move people towards from
academic prototypes maybe shakey once
very usable once but we understood that
people may be coming in with just
academic prototypes that were used to
produce papers and so the very first
thing you have to do if you want to
compete just give us a data set use
whatever code you have give us a
correctly formatted formatted synthetic
data set if you come to the sequestered
rounds then we need a standardized input
we're going to give it the data at Delta
and epsilon value you can't hard code
the schema we'll give you the schema it
will be very similar but there may be
differences in column names and so on
and thorough code documentation that's
aligned with your algorithm
documentation this is reviewed by
multiple subject matter experts the
things are run by the tech leads if we
encounter problems your informed and you
may get to resubmit and so you leave if
you get a prize you'll leave with money
but everybody who comes to this question
batch leaves with an externally
evaluated codebase they'll be more
easily shared tested and used by other
researchers potentially forming a stable
basis for further production level saw
software solutions so this is my offer
participate in the contest and we'll
provide a free two month boot camp for
your DP synthetic data solution all you
got to do on Sunday or any time of the
next five weeks is sign up on top coder
send us three data sets of three values
of epsilon and we will walk you through
the process of having a system that
other people can use that is well
documented that it's easy to understand
all right so here I'm gonna do the same
my contestants do you get email
notifications on your phone this is
nothing that the winners announcement so
so this is when I press post and there
we go now everybody online knows so you
guys get to know here we go
alright so we're going to be using the
1940 census persons level data for
Colorado which is where PSCR is based as
our provisional data first requested
phase data it will not be Colorado all
right for scoring to catch long tails we
are going to be using income inequality
based metrics so both of the things we
had done previously in the matches were
bucketed we will not be bucketing this
match and to catch degradation of
accuracy over differences of differences
we're going to be doing pay gap based
metrics which in 1940 are going to
survive synthetic data okay final
outcomes so sixty-two thousand dollars
in prizes and then if I do my math right
that's five times four thousand for
people who open source that gets me the
eighty thousand eighty two we would very
much like to see open source solutions
coming out of this there will be further
nist research as a metrology lab to
identify and establish metrics or
methods for evaluating synthetic data
there are two open problems here
one is generating the data but the other
very much in this wheelhouse is
measuring the data and also we would
like to demo
disseminate the lessons learned and the
approach is taken through journal
special issues potentially conferences
workshops talks and challenge
participants will be invited to
contribute so i would very much like to
see many more teams join us for match
three and more information on this will
be forthcoming
and they're you know it's how to find us
any questions any incredibly quick
questions it can be open or closed it's
entirely voluntary I would very much we
are offering four thousand dollars for
the top five winners to open source
their solutions people do have their the
rights to hang on to their IP so it is
only we invite you to open source yes
yes uh so what there is mmm seconds here
if you google the contest and as it was
suggested
you will find links to the the problem
statements and this is on the top cutter
website and that you will actually find
not just a detailed description of the
scoring but also code you can just run
the code and do it yourself